hey 42 here in 1878 Charles Darwin's
cousin Explorer inventor and polymath
Sir Francis Galton discovered a new
technique to combine portraits to create
a composite image an average face what
he discovered was that whenever you
average people's faces to create a new
face the resulting composite face is
always beautiful he thus concluded that
as humans we find averages beautiful we
dislike extremes anomalies and oddities
Sir Francis Galton deduced that facial
symmetry as well as averageness both
contribute to beauty around the same
time that Sir Francis Galton published
his research a Polish businessman by the
name of Maximilian factor ovitch took
immense interest in what Galton had to
say about Beauty Galton's findings
inspired Maximilian
to create a strange device which he
called the beauty micrometer its purpose
was to measure a woman's face and check
for averageness and symmetry it was able
to pick up on minor structural flaws
that were barely noticeable to the human
eye women flocked in their droves mostly
from the film industry to try out
Maximilian's new device conveniently he
also happened to produce and sell a
range of Beauty enhancing products to
fixed her so-called imperfections that
the beauty micrometer picked up on he
named these products makeup so
successful was his range of makeup that
he started a company named after himself
Maximilian Durov itch Max Factor
which as you all know would become one
of the largest makeup brands in the
world but this raises a poignant
question why do we find symmetry and
averageness to be beautiful why aren't
quirky Arden disfigured face is
considered beautiful by most people
researchers have longed for that the
reason for this is that imperfect
asymmetrical faces can indicate that
potential mates have an ailment or a
disease and so the laws of sexual
selection dictate that we are
predisposed to choose not to mate with
such people because they may produce
unfavorable offspring although this is
not a very nice theory it does make
sense after all it's true that various
diseases we can have as children do
leave permanent scars and physical
disfigurement on your face and body in
some cases albeit less so today with
modern medicine but if this were true
wouldn't so-called ugliness and physical
imperfections have died out long ago
through sexual selection kind of like a
natural eugenics well there must be more
to this beauty thing than wanting to
avoid a disease and genetic disorders
also today with modern medicine
illnesses we have as children such as
chickenpox rarely leave any permanent
physical marks and our faces as they
would have done so in our
hunter-gatherer days the answer to why
we find symmetrical faces so beautiful
could in fact be so simple it's almost
beautiful some scientists think it's
simply because humans find beauty in all
things symmetrical in nature symmetry
represents order calmness uncertainty it
is the opposite of chaos so seeing
symmetry whether it's in nature or a
significant of his face makes us feel
calm and content
be it the wings of a butterfly the
orderly leaves of a plants all the
gentle ripples in a pond all these sites
bring girls peace the same chemical
reactions that caused these feelings of
content could also be triggered by the
symmetry in a person's face but Beauty
can also be found in learning new skills
and nowhere else more so than Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes that
enable you to achieve true beauty in
your work whether your fingers
photography art design or something else
Skillshare has an online course taught
by an expert to help you become great at
what you do or what you want to do
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and just
do the work you love if you are
passionate about photography I highly
recommend checking out the Skillshare
course documentary photography capturing
places and people you'll learn all the
techniques and skills you need to
artfully capture the beauty around you
and in the places you visit Skillshare
is also more affordable and most
learning platforms an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month
and since Skillshare is sponsoring this
video the first 1,000 people to use the
promo link in the description will get
their first two months for only 99 cents
but can beauty be measured like we
measure intelligence turns out yes
believe it or not that is a unit of
measurement for beauty it's called a
helm the more beautiful you are the more
helens you possess no I've not gone
crazy again I forgot to mention that
it's meant as a joke coined by Cambridge
mathematician
wuah rooster it comes from the fact that
people would write that Helen of Troy
was so beautiful that she had
quote-unquote a face that launched a
foul
ships and so the more helens a person
has the more likely their beauty is to
inspire actions in others such as waging
war on one's behalf there are also
millions for situations when someone
it's so darn ugly that they are simply
not deserving of one full hello
according to the Oxford English
Dictionary Beauty is defined as a
combination of qualities such as shape
color or form that pleases the aesthetic
senses especially the sight now this
suggests that beauty is subjective and
since we are all unique and we all find
pleasure in different ways it is true
that beauty must be in the eyes of the
beholder
so then maybe perfect symmetry
averageness and physical proportions to
set norms aren't true beauty well this
of course depends on your point of view
but the Japanese have a novel way of
approaching the idea of beauty that I
personally find rather appealing indeed
they call it wabi-sabi
wabi-sabi is the appreciation and
natural beauty found within
imperfections this isn't just another
ancient Eastern tradition that is mostly
ignored by modern society
wabi-sabi is deeply ingrained within
modern Japanese culture it's even taught
in schools right Leonardo Orin wrote
that wabi-sabi is the most conspicuous
and characteristic feature of
traditional Japanese beauty and it
occupies roughly the same position in
the Japanese pantheon of aesthetic
values as do the Greek ideals of beauty
and perfection in the West
wabi-sabi is loving that mole on your
partner's cheek it is appreciating the
way that crooked old tree warps and
twists in its eternal struggle against
gravity it is loving the curves bumps
and oddities of a person's body and
finding beauty in the way that cracks me
under through your
favorite architectural monoliths the
famous Zen garden in Northwest Kyoto
contains 15 stones that are placed in
such a way that no matter what angle you
look at them from on the ground you can
only ever see 14 stones the 15th is
always just out of sight thus
symbolizing wabi-sabi no matter how you
see the garden it is never complete
never perfect
the idea of wabi-sabi comes from
Buddhism but it truly originated from
Japanese tea ceremonies as people would
favor unique handcrafted cups on tea
making apparatus that had imperfections
and unique marks from their makers hands
over perfect ornate crockery which is
only intended to show off wabi-sabi is a
deeply complex ideal and a way of living
that cannot be fully explained using the
english language but it's a refreshingly
beautiful take on beauty compared to the
obsession of striving for perfection and
symmetry that is often promoted in the
West
speaking of perfection it turns out that
it's not all it's cracked up to be
a study on catwalk models discovered
that the more symmetrical and
technically perfect a models face is the
more likely they are to have low
self-esteem ins generally have a lower
well-being than average our research is
conducted at City University in London
found that people who make a living from
their looks such as catwalk and catalog
models were more suspicious
non-conforming intensely emotional into
personally alienated eccentric and
self-centered but it turns out that
there are also considerable benefits to
what society would call beautiful these
studies also mentions that more
physically attractive people are
considerably more likely to be hired and
to be promoted
on average attractive individuals earn
highest salaries they are also more
confident it's for that this is because
they put themselves out there more often
and have thus had more experience at
making conversation and socializing
however vanity and striving for
perfection can be dangerous and lead you
into a pit of misery a recent study by
london-based Royal Society of Public
Health found that Instagram is the worst
social network for mental health
researchers found that a desire to take
perfect sugar-coated images of one's own
life in an attempt to gain likes
followers and keep up with one's peers
only increased mental issues such as
depression anxiety and feelings of FOMO
fear of missing out interestingly this
study found YouTube to be the most
positive social network on the Internet
being the only social network in
existence that scored positive marks for
mental health so that's good I've talked
in past videos about how damaging social
media to the mental health of young
people today truly is but these recent
studies showed how it's the way that
Instagram and other sites like Facebook
only show the very best of other
people's lives that is so mentally
damaging when all we see is our friends
edited and cherry picked photos on
holiday or having a good time with their
friends it makes us feel self-contempt
like we are missing out on life some
people may compensate by manufacturing
their own scenarios so that they can
post pictures on Instagram that make
their own lives appear better than they
are to try and rival their friends which
is always a futile and empty pursuit
only adding fuel to this vicious cycle
the study also found that the
worst-affected are women seeing
airbrushed images of over women on
Instagram with
perfect bodies hair and makeup makes
women feel inadequate as if their bodies
and looks aren't as good as their peers
Instagram may seem harmless on the
surface and sure it can be and is used
harmlessly by many people but sadly for
many other people it's just a mechanism
for them to put a filter on their own
life and show it off to the world hey
I'm not judging we're all guilty myself
included but next time you're obsessing
over how perfectly you can filter and
showcase your figure your holiday snaps
or just your lunch on Instagram or
Facebook maybe you should just take a
moment to indulge in some wabi-sabi and
instead put your phone down and
appreciate the subtleties and beautiful
imperfections of the world around you
the leaves on the ground the landscape
the insightful interesting conversation
of the people around you full true
beauty is not what you see or what you
strive to be but it is too fantastical
wonder and the greatness of life which
you experience every day and equally so
that which you give to others thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon also I'd like to thank
Skillshare once again for sponsoring
this video don't forget to check them
out by using the promo link in the
description to really help out the
channel and learn some great new skills
for yourself